why you should learn how to train an
automl image classification model automl
vision is part of vertex Ai and helps
you to train machine learning models to
classify images according to your own
defined labels for instance are these
hot dogs or legs wanna try it out this
tutorial teaches you how to use image
data to train a multi-label
classification model you'll create a
Vertex AI data set using a publicly
available data set of flower images
hosted on cloud storage then you'll
train an image classification model with
this data set using automl and voila
just like that you have a trained automl
model that you can then deploy to
request predictions check out the pinned
comment for a link to the tutorial now
you know